En esta ocasión,
quiero intentar resolver la siguiente desigualdad...
la siguiente desigualdad que dice,
"x" cuadrada más "3x"...
más "3x"...
esto quiero que sea más grande que 10.
Y bueno,
justo ahora, es el momento
en donde debes de pausar el vídeo
e intentar hacerlo por ti mismo,
pero antes, quiero darte un consejo,
intenta trabajar esta desigualdad,
como si fuera una ecuación cuadrática,
solo que cuando llegues al final,
reflexiona un poco,
sobre lo que te está diciendo esta desigualdad.
Ok, voy a suponer que ya trabajaste esta desigualdad
y vamos a resolverla,
para esto, lo primero que voy a hacer es
restar 10 de ambos lados de esta desigualdad.
Y me va a quedar... déjame cambiar de color...
me va a quedar "x" cuadrada, ok,
más "3x", ok, menos 10...
menos 10...
el signo de la desigualdad se conserva,
se mantiene igual,
porque recuerda que cuando yo resto,
o sumó algo de ambos lados de la desigualdad,
la desigualdad se conserva.
Esto va a ser más grande, quiero que sea más grande
que 10 menos 10 lo cual es 0.
Ok y fíjate que aquí
tenemos la expresión cuadrática,
la cual por cierto podemos factorizar.
Si nos fijamos en
"x" cuadrada más "3x" menos 10
vamos a pensar en dos números que
multiplicados me den -10 ,
vamos a factorizarlo así,
y que se suman...
que su suma me dé 3 positivo.
Cuál es la pareja de numerosos
cuya multiplicación, cuyo producto es -10
y cuya suma es 3 positivo, ¿existirá?
Pues pensemos un poco en el 10,
qué par de números multiplicándose nos da 10,
bueno puedo pensar en 10 y 1,
pero 10 menos 1 no es 3,
y por otra parte,
-10 más 1 no es 3 tampoco...
Ehh.. se me ocurre 5 y 2,
5 por 2 es 10... 5 por -2 es -10
y 5 menos 2 es 3 positivo
perfecto, ya los encontramos,
los números son 5 y -2
ahora ten cuidado de que el -
quede al lado del 2,
porque si yo pongo -5 y 2,
también me daría su multiplicación -10,
su producto -10, sin embargo,
cuando yo me tomé la suma, me va a quedar -3
y en este caso 5 por -2 es -10
y 5 más -2 es 3.
De lujo, entonces ya puedo
escribir esta expresión de aquí,
justo esto que tengo aquí,
de la siguiente manera,
como,
"x" más 5...
"x" más 5, esto a su vez multiplica,
esto que a su vez multiplica
a "x" menos 2... a "x" menos 2...
Ok, espera, déjame ponerlo con el mismo color...
a "x" menos 2...
y esto me dicen que tiene que ser
más grande que 0, ok,
Ahora,
date cuenta que si tuviéramos una igualdad,
ya hubiéramos acabado el problema,
porque aquí está diciendo,
que tengo
dos números multiplicado igual a 0,
si fuese una igualdad,
y entonces diría o el primero es 0
o el segundo es 0 y ya acabé el problema.
sin embargo aquí tengo una desigualdad
tengo dos números multiplicándose,
"x" más 5 por "x" menos 2
que me tienen que dar un valor más grande que 0.
Y justo en este momento es a lo que me refería
con que reflexionaras,
a qué se refiere
esta expresión que tengo aquí.
Fíjate bien, si yo tuviera dos números,
imagínate que tengo "a"
"a" lo voy a multiplicar por "b"...
voy a multiplicarlo por "b"
y esto...
esto a su vez,
yo digo que es más grande que 0,
¿a qué me refiero con esto?
Bueno, si tengo "a" por "b" más grande que 0,
estoy diciendo,
que ambos deben de tener el mismo signo,
porque si te das cuenta algo positivo, por algo positivo,
me da algo positivo
es decir, algo más grande que 0,
o en su dado caso algo negativo, por algo negativo,
me da algo positivo,
es decir, algo más grande que 0
y eso es muy importante,
es la reflexión que yo quería que tú hicieras.
Fíjate bien "a" por "b" más grande que 0
esto quiere decir que
ehhh... vamos a ponerlo así,
ya sea...
y déjame ponerlo con otro color
para que no nos confundamos...
ya
sea
que "a" sea más grande que 0...
ok, que "a" sea más grande que 0...
más grande que 0...
y a su vez también "b"
y eso es muy importante,
déjame de ponerlo con este color...
y también "b" sea más grande que 0,
"b" estaba el color rojo...
y "b" sea más grande que 0,
ok, ya sea que "a" sea más grande que 0
y veces más grandes que 0,
o en su dado caso...
que pase lo contrario, que "a" sea menor que 0,
que "a" sea un número negativo, sea menor que 0,
y además que "b" sea menor que 0,
y que "b" también sea menor que 0
es decir, que ambos sean números negativos,
o ambos son positivos,
o ambos son negativos
y eso es muy importante, esto tiene que pasar
para que se cumpla esta desigualdad que tengo aquí,
ahora, regresemos a este caso
que estoy analizando.
Si yo tengo que "x" más 5 por "x" menos 2
tiene que ser más grande que 0,
estoy diciendo o que "x" más 5 es más grande que 0
y "x" menos 2 es más grande que 0,
o que "x" más 5 es menor que 0 y
"x" menos 2, es menor que 0.
Y vamos a ponerlo,
se me ocurre tomar este mismo color para "a"
y para "x" menos 5,
ok, voy a ponerlo así,
que "x" más 5...
que "x" más 5, sea más grande que 0,
y a su vez... ok... vamos a ponerlo...
y a su vez "x" menos 2
también sea más grande que 0
Mmm... déjame ponerlo con color rojo
"x" menos 2 sea más grande que 0, ok,
que pase esto o en su dado caso...
o en su dado caso,
o
que pase que "x" más 5...
que "x" más 5 ,
esto sea menor que 0...
y a su vez al mismo tiempo...
y al mismo tiempo... que "x"menos 2...
que "x" menos 2,
también sea menor que 0...
también sea menor que 0
y estoy utilizando justo esta información
y estos datos que acabamos de obtener,
justo aquí a la derecha,
o que ambos son positivos,
o que ambos son negativos,
y son las únicas dos formas
en que pase esta desigualdad que tengo aquí.
Ok, pues vamos a analizar
las dos con mucha calma.
imagínate que yo tengo que
"x" más 5 es más grande que 0,
y "x" menos 2 es más grande que 0,
vamos a ponerlo así,
aunque "x" más 5...
"x" más 5 sea más grande que 0, ok,
y
al mismo tiempo...
déjame cambiar de color...
y al mismo tiempo que "x" menos 2
también sea más grande que 0
que "x" menos 2,
sea más grande que 0.
Esto qué quiere decir, bueno, de aquí podemos despejar a "x"
y podremos obtener qué "x"
es más grande que -5,
y a su vez estamos pidiendo,
al mismo tiempo estamos pidiendo,
que "x" sea más grande que...
"x" sea más grande que 2,
lo único que hice este lado fue restar 5
de ambos lados de la desigualdad,
y de este lado lo que hice fue sumar 2
de ambos lados de la desigualdad.
En el primer caso...
en el primer caso...
"x" es más grande que -5
y "x" es más grande que 2,
que por cierto, estos dos
los podemos juntar en una misma oración.
Un número que sea más grande que -5
y un número que sea más grande que 2,
bueno, en general son los números
que son más grandes que 2,
si yo tengo un número,
"x" más grande que 2
si yo tengo un número que es más grande que 2,
también va a ser más grande que -5.
Ahora bien,
date cuenta que no pasa lo contrario,
si yo tengo un número más grande que -5,
por ejemplo el 0,
el 0 no es más grande que 2 y yo lo que quiero
es que se cumplan ambas desigualdades,
quiero los números que sean más grandes que -5
y a su vez que sean más grandes que 2,
y por lo tanto,
los únicos que cumplen eso,
son los números que son más grandes que dos,
es decir, de estas dos,
lo estoy juntando y lo estoy sintetizando
en esta desigualdad que tengo aquí, ok,
esto es el primer caso,
que pase esto de aquí.
Ahora, también tenemos un segundo caso,
este de aquí,
y en el segundo caso, lo que me dice,
es que "x" más 5 sea
menor que 0,
voy a ponerlo aquí, "x" más 5 sea menor que 0,
y a su vez que "x" menos 2...
déjame cambiar de color...
sea menor que 0,
que "x" menos 2 sea menor que 0,
y bueno de aquí puedo despejar,
de aquí tengo que,
"x" más 5 es menor que 0, sí,
"x" es menor que -5, lo único que hice,
fue restar 5 de ambos lados de la desigualdad
y a su vez...
y a su vez se cumplan,
estoy buscando también los números que
cumplan que "x" menos 2 sea menor que 0,
esto quiere decir,
que "x" sea más pequeño que 2.
Ok, estoy buscando los números que sean menores
que -5 y a su vez que sean menores que 2,
y si te das cuenta esto de aquí...
esto de aquí,
lo podemos sintetizar todo esto
en los números que son más pequeños que -5.
Todo número que es más pequeño que -5
es más pequeño que 2, pero ten cuidado,
de igual manera que aquí a la izquierda,
no todo número que es más pequeño que 2,
es más pequeño que -5,
debes de tener cuidado.
Yo lo que quiero que se cumplan
ambas desigualdades simultáneamente ,
es decir, imagínate que te tomas al 0,
0 sería menor que 2,
pero no es menor que -5,
yo lo que busco son los números
que cumplan ambas desigualdades,
y bueno, la solución de ambas desigualdades
son los números que son menores que -5.
¡Y ya está!
mi respuesta de este problema,
ya estamos a punto de obtenerla,
son o las "x" que son más grandes que 2
ó
las "x" que son más chicas que -5
y esa es la respuesta,
los números
que son más grandes que -2, ok,
o en su dado caso,
los números que son más pequeños que -5,
los que son más pequeños que -5.
Y aquí está,
aquí tenemos la respuesta
Ahora, lo que quiero que te des cuenta, es que esto de aquí,
lo podemos graficar en una recta numérica,
si yo pongo la recta numérica...
vamos a ponerle aquí arriba
si yo pongo una recta numérica por aquí,
ok, este es mi eje "x"... este es mi eje x...
y supongamos que
este es el valor de 0, ok,
por aquí tengo 1
y por aquí tengo al 2, ok,
y del otro lado tengo aquí al -1...
-1.... por aquí tengo al -2,
ok, por aquí tengo al -3, ok,
por aquí al -4
y por aquí al -5.
Mi solución de esta desigualdad que tengo aquí
con la que empecé,
"x" cuadrada más "3x" es más grande que 10,
son los números que son más grandes que 2,
ok, vamos a ponerlo así,
son los números que son más grandes que 2
y ojo es una desigualdad estricta,
por lo tanto no toca al 2
entonces voy a poner un circulito aquí,
más grandes que 2
son todos estos de aquí, ok,
y por otra parte tengo las "x",
las "x" que son más pequeñas que -5,
entonces voy a tomar este color...
me fijo en el -5,
pongo también un circulito abierto
porque es una desigualdad estricta,
me voy a fijar en todos los menores a -5,
todos los que van por acá, ok,
y bueno,
tú puedes corroborar que esto realmente es cierto,
imagínate que te tomas un número más grande que 2,
supongamos 3,
3 al cuadrado es 9,
9 más 9 es 18,
que es un número más grande que 10,
eso sí se cumple, estamos bien,
y también podemos probar
con un número más pequeño que -5,
se me ocurre -6,
-6 al cuadrado es 36,
36 menos 18,
36 menos 18 es 18,
que es un número grande que 10.
Y ya está, la solución de esta desigualdad
con la que empezamos,
de esta que tenemos aquí,
es justo esta que tenemos acá abajo.